(man crying)
- Hey, friend.
Is, uh, is everything okay?
(man crying)
- It is good, just fine.
- [Woman] You sure?
Buddy?
- Hey, Anna, do you have the, uh.
(man crying)
- What happened?
What did you do to Elliot?
- Elliot. That's his name.
- New guy.
- I didn't do anything to Elliot,
he was crying when I got here.
- Hey man, do you want a k puff?
(mumbling) puts them in the fridge.
(man crying)
- What the hell did you guys do to,
I want to say Elmore.
- Elijah and Calen was rude to him.
- What, you can't even
remember Elliot's name.
- I don't think his name is Elliot.
- Oh my God.
- Hey, is it, uh, office blues?
Was it the boss lady?
Is it your penis?
- What?
- I just feel like if I had a penis
and something happened, I'd cry
and wear a little dick sling.
Big dick sling, sorry.
- Why aren't we working?
What did you mutton chops
do to poor Elliot this time?
- Elliot (in unison)
- I've been saying that.
- What happened?
- Nothing happened,
okay, he was crying when I got here,
and I tried to help him.
- Well he was crying when I got here too,
but I closed my door and
let him cry in peace.
Gave him some dignity.
- I'm, I'm sorry everyone, it's just.
- [man] No, it's okay Elliot.
- You don't have to
explain your emotions man,
just ride them out.
- But I think.
- Ah ah, this is a safe space.
A safe, productive space.
- Let's just forget it happened, man.
- I think if I talk about it.
- No time for tears.
If you insist on crying,
I guess you can do it in my office.
- Okay.
- Really?
(man crying)
- Has he even stopped
to go to the bathroom?
- Nah, he's just been working it out.
(man crying)
- Have a good one.
- [woman] Tell us what's going on.
- My cat got aten by another cat.
(man crying)
- [man] I've got to be
honest, that sounds awesome.
(laughter)